[Music]
welcome everybody i'm alexander rose i'm
the executive director here at long now
and a while back when uh when i saw this
book come out i realized that there's so
many times where we have talks with from
astronomers about billions of years or
geologists about millions of years but
you know there's this one passage that
when stuart brand launched long now he
wrote
in the kind of launching essay which was
civilization is revving itself into a
pathologically short attention span the
trends might be coming from the
acceleration of technology the short
horizon perspective of market-driven
economics the next election perspective
of democracies or the distractions
personal multitasking
all are on the increase some sort of
balancing corrective to the
short-sightedness is needed and that was
what launched long now and we have we've
kind of dealt with a lot of those
subjects but it's very rare that we deal
with that personal multitasking part and
so when i saw this book i thought it was
a perfect opportunity to kind of look
not at necessarily the next ten thousand
years but at least the arc of our lives
and how we think about that in a more
personal way and dory clark is perfect
person to tell us about that thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
so we've all been through a lot
over the last couple of years
we had to recalibrate
we had to suddenly discover terminology
that we had never used before social
distancing we suddenly had to
stand in line at the grocery store we
suddenly had to
find new ways of relating to each other
we
fled from downtown
and certainly that was the case in san
francisco as well as new york and
started
living our lives in so many ways online
and we had to do it fast
there had been you know for 15 20 years
scholars
of
the study of work from home and remote
work and how could it how could it
possibly function and what would it look
like and what would it take for
companies to be able to accede to this
future that everybody thought was
inevitable but would happen over the
course of decades and it turns out of
course that somehow we figured it out
because we had to
in the course of two or three weeks we
were all thrown into it and we
discovered pretty rapidly that there was
a downside to that that we would have to
cope with
but we did we figured it out the
pandemic forced us to adapt
even
the poor
unloved for so long
qr code
finally got its day in the sun
i feel happy for the qr code
but
the truth of all of this
is we saw over the past two years
what short-term thinking can do
i'm not here to knock short-term
thinking we need the ability to pivot to
adapt to be agile
short-term thinking has its place
and it can't be the only way that we
operate
i wrote a book that came out last fall
called the long game how to be a
long-term thinker in a short-term world
and for me one of the questions i really
wanted to explore was how can we
actually apply
the principles of long-term thinking the
principles of strategic thinking to our
own lives to our own careers
many of us do this for our businesses
for those of you who you know are
entrepreneurs or you work inside
organizations this is this is something
that we consciously try to do you know
where are we going in five years in 10
years and 20 years
we often fail though to really apply
that same lens to our own lives
there was a study that was done a few
years ago by an organization called the
management research group
they surveyed 10
000 senior leaders and of the 10
000
97
said that the single most important
thing they could do
for the future of their organization for
their organization's success was to be
better long-term thinkers
97 percent literally almost everyone
thinks this is a good idea
and yet
a separate study that was done around
the same time
96
of the leaders surveyed said they didn't
have time
for strategic thinking
there is a huge disconnect going on in
our own lives we have to look at a
longer time frame than almost anybody is
used to a time frame that is far beyond
our own lifetimes
in order to
make smarter choices and better
decisions
but i know also
it can be challenging sometimes when we
look at these timelines that are
too big for the human mind to even
really comprehend
to think about how it plays out in our
day-to-day how do we apply it how do we
live it what does it look like
and
what it reminded me of
is a quote from
rabbi tarfan
this is somebody who lived
2 000 years ago
just after the destruction of the second
temple in 79 a.d
and
he said you're not required
to complete the work
of perfecting the world
but neither are you permitted
to desist
from trying
we can't do it all we have to recognize
that we have to make peace with it
we're not going to get it all done
but there are things that we can do
there are things in fact
that we have to do that we are called
upon to do
i wanted to share with you seven
strategies that i hope might be helpful
that
have informed my thinking
and
might be useful to you one of the things
that i realized is that
for so many of us what is lacking what
is profoundly lacking
in our lives
is white space
in a very literal sense for most of us
if you
look at your calendar
you're probably going to see a sea of
blue
literally white space
time that is unspoken for
is probably pretty scarce
it's not the worst thing in the world
but it has its consequences
a few years ago
i interviewed david allen and
he told me something interesting
he said it doesn't take a huge amount of
time to have brilliant ideas
but what it takes
is space
it's almost like a zen coan if you roll
it around in your head
but it's true right i mean we all know
if you have to come up with some
innovation some new idea it's not oh i
need to set aside 40 hours and bang my
head against the desk that is not how
the brilliant ideas come
right
it comes
sometimes in a moment in a flash you're
in the shower you're walking you're
jogging you're doing something
but what enables it to come
is having the space to make the
connections
we will never get that space
if we are constantly pulled down
by details
by worries by ruminations and by
back-to-back meetings that are so
intense we feel we can never catch up
we need white space if we are going to
have the mental bandwidth to be able to
even begin to engage in long-term
thinking
to be able to step back enough from our
present circumstances to entertain those
questions
number two
if we are ever to truly excel at
something if we're willing to
take what's necessary to be great we
have to be willing to choose what to be
bad at what are we willing to give up to
get there
most of us refuse to choose
and by not choosing
we stay average
that's when i learned that long-term
thinking
is in a lot of ways a test of character
it's a test of the courage
to make choices
i'll give you an example there was a
bank that was actually a very successful
bank
and this bank they did something
interesting unlike almost every other
bank these guys stayed open really late
they were open till 8 o'clock weeknights
they were open on weekends
fantastic their customers loved it
obviously
but why doesn't every bank do it you
probably know the answer which is that
it's expensive
but what this bank did
they found a way to pay for it
the way they paid for it
is
they took the savings rate the rate on
savings deposits they shrunk it down
they made it almost non-existent it was
kind of terrible
but to their customers it didn't really
matter
it was a lot more important it was a lot
more salient to be able to go to the
bank at 7 30 at night
but most companies are not willing to
make those hard choices and most people
are not either
number three
we also have to balance our portfolio
for most of us if you literally know one
thing about personal finance which you
probably know is that it is a bad idea
to put all your eggs in one basket right
you don't want to own one stock
most people think that's a pretty bad
idea you want to balance your portfolio
you want to have some of your money in
cash and some of your money in moonshots
so often
we tend to just
focus in we have our day job okay we're
doing our day job the rest of our time
might be taken up with family or other
responsibilities
i want to urge you to think about
carving out time maybe twenty percent is
too much fine
you can find five percent but to think
about what your speculative long-term
activity is what is your learning edge
where are you
growing something that comes up a lot
when it comes to
long-term thinking and pursuing
long-term projects
is
this question of
when and whether to quit
it can almost feel like you're going
into a dark tunnel
right
because you don't really know
what's going on you don't really know
for sure
if it's working
in the midst of developing an
exponential technology there is
something that they dubbed the deception
phase
now what is that
if you're
moving forward with digital photography
and you're able to get it from point
zero one pixels to point zero two pixels
to point zero four pixels
that's actually kind of amazing right
0.08
when moving on and on it's actually kind
of amazing progression it's doubling
it's doubling it's doubling but the
problem
is that
it's still
invisible to the naked eye
the world around you unless they are
looking very closely they can't tell the
difference and you know
or you hope
you think you know
that you're making progress but it's
often very very hard to drown out the
voices of all the people around you
saying
it's so overblown
that's the deception phase
once we make enough progress to get from
1 to 2 to 4 to 16
all of a sudden people start to say whoa
where did that come from
it's been doubling all along
they just couldn't see it
but for so many of us
if we're working on a project that's
important to us
if we are
building a career
things take time
number five
strategic patience
sometimes things do take a while
and that can be exceptionally annoying
i don't like it that they take a while
sometimes but you know what being mad at
the seed does not make the seed grow
faster it takes however long it takes
jeff bezos
was interviewed and they asked him what
is it
that is amazon's competitive advantage
why is amazon so successful
and what he said i think is quite
powerful he said amazon is willing to
invest on a seven year time frame
if it takes seven years for something to
show a profit
it's okay
he said our competitors are only willing
to invest on a three year time frame
they have to turn a profit within that
time frame if they don't they're going
to scrap it they're not even going to
try it
that is the competitive advantage
if we can be willing
to out weight and out last the people
around us
if we can be
willing to endure the deception phase
for longer
it enables us to tackle
bigger
harder more meaningful more strategic
problems
number six
fail fast
we know
that failure
in many places around the world is
stigmatized pretty heavily you get one
chance you blow it all right sorry no
more chances
it's also important to recognize
that something is not a failure
until you call it
it's not a failure until you stop trying
the last point that i wanted to make is
that as we think
about our own long-term
future our own long-term vision
in a lot of ways the
north star that we can look to
is a really simple question
what kind of person
do you want to be
this is
a friend of mine her name is alyssa cohn
i write about her alyssa maybe like some
of you guys was a huge hamilton fan
when she learned that lin-manuel miranda
had a new side project they created
an academy
it was a training program to teach
regular people how to do freestyle hip
hop rap just like the performers
she immediately said i'm in that sounds
great
she shows up for class
and when she shows up she realizes it's
alyssa
and about 20
guys who are all about two decades
younger than her and who are all
extremely good rappers
after the first class she emailed the
instructor and she said i'm really sorry
to do this i feel like i should withdraw
i i it's just you know i don't fit in i
don't i don't think i can do this
and he wrote back to her
with some incredibly wise words
he said alyssa
the goal
is not to turn you into a professional
rapper
the goal
is to help you become a more creative
and uninhibited person
and she thought about it and she
realized
oh right
that is my goal
she spent two months
every monday night taking the hip hop
improv beatbox rap classes
and just before
the world shut down in 2020 she gave a
concert performance with her class and
she had friends from all over see her
perform improv rap but ultimately the
question that i think all of us can ask
ourselves
as we think long term as we think about
our vision for our own lives and how we
want to lead them
is what kind of person do you want to be
what are you
optimizing for
with that
i'm going to
open it up for the conversation with
xander and i'm so glad to be here thank
you
thank
you let's see
well that was great sorry um the
i think one of the things that you
brought up in the book that um
that i appreciated is that this idea
that we kind of obsess on on being busy
and you know you ask somebody how
they're doing and often the answer is
i'm so busy
but also that that is a reflection on
um making us feel important and how that
one of the things you kind of have to
get over this
what i came to realize
was in a lot of ways
our
in our contemporary american society
so much of our sense of personal meaning
derives from work
from you know the the work that we do or
who we are in the professional world i
realized that
philosophy and theology actually aren't
that far off from it that if we
really want to to meet people where
they're at and address their sense of
who they are in the world and what is
the impact they can make in the world
that bringing some of these
philosophical considerations to bear
is important there's been some
fascinating research uh notably by
sylvia bellezza at columbia university
that's talked about exactly this point
that in many cultures most notably
american culture busyness really is a
form of status signaling that we are
essentially
finding a kind of politically correct
way of saying oh i'm so popular i'm so
in demand
i'm awesome
and
it's uh
we don't necessarily think of ourselves
as doing it but it's actually a little
bit obnoxious and we need to stop
right yeah i mean i think the
the true the true power is being able to
schedule the downtime which i think you
know you talked about and one of my
favorite things is when i'm going to do
a trip or something and then all of a
sudden it gets canceled and then i
realize i have this openness in my
calendar um but i think it's an
interesting idea of how to have you
thought about some of the techniques for
how how to do this in your life
yeah yeah absolutely when it comes to
actually you know sort of managing
calendars and carving things out
one of the the principles that has been
most helpful to me uh again to give a
little silicon valley shout out is a
concept that paul graham the founder of
y combinator has talked about
he's written about manager schedule and
maker schedule and the way that it's
sort of played out in his essay was you
think about you know a manager at a tech
company and they're having meetings
they're supervising things they're
keeping the projects going uh
makers in in his world probably coders
are people who need large blocks of
unstructured time so they can dive in
and immerse themselves in projects
what i've actually found is that for
most professionals certainly this is
true for me
we actually kind of have to do both
right it can't be one or the other and
so i've modified this and in terms of my
own scheduling i have
for the past few years followed a
principle where i have what i call
maker days and manager days and so i
deliberately try to
pack all my meetings into one or two
days so that i'm just kind of going i'm
knocking them out and then frankly those
retiring days but what it enables what
it allows is for me to have the
completely unstructured maker days and i
use that for writing or for you know
so-called deep work
which is actually quite quite effective
to be able to do it it's it's really
hard to get into high quality work when
you only have a you know half an hour in
between meetings i'm actually curious i
mean it's it's a little bit of a heavy
mantle to uh to be running the log now
foundation and to in some ways be this
like you know paragon of
long-term thinking and yet have to run
an organization that has so many
day-to-day responsibilities like any
organization how do you thread that
needle how do you feel like you try to
live out the principles in terms of how
you conduct your work yeah i mean
obviously if you're trying to run a ten
thousand organization you have to keep
that perspective but you also have to
get some things done um and so that um i
think it's it's a balance but i think
what's what's nice about having that
perspective is that i and you had a
slide up here is that you don't have to
finish the work
um and so that i think to that point
it's to me it's like how do i start the
work in a way that somebody else can
finish it and that i can hand it off at
some point um but it's it's actually
very much on our mind right now because
we could we're just passing 25 years and
we we are going to have to do a
generational shift so
one of the projects i've been working on
is researching how everybody else has
had long-term institutions so it's very
early in that research show i don't have
the answers yet but i hope to get a lot
of good stories from the longest lived
organizations in the world and be able
to come back and and talk about them at
some point so yeah it's uh it's very
much on my mind
um
for sure and i think the
you mentioned like how you know when
when you have good ideas is not when
you're overworked
um and you know the certainly the best
ideas you know that i've ever had have
come in the interstitial times um but
you also have to load that with the
brain like with the parts of it that
um
kind of inform you to it and so that
balance is something that i'm curious at
what you think about it's how do you get
enough kind of
the information in in but then have the
down time to to think about it
yeah it is it is an interesting balance
and an interesting challenge i remember
when i was in college and when i was in
graduate school
i actually
stopped reading for pleasure i'm not
sure if this was the case for for other
people as well but i had always been as
a kid a huge reader i loved reading
and
now you know as an adult i read all the
time
but
when i was in school and was essentially
being forced
to read hundreds of pages of pretty
dense text every week
when it became my job
it was no longer fun to do it
recreationally and something that had
been quite important to me kind of
atrophied in that way
and i think
that
for me one of the concepts that i was
mentioning in the talk about white space
i think part of why that's so resonant
is that what i've come to believe is
that for a lot of us you know for a lot
of you know
white-collar knowledge workers
the truth is
most of our jobs are actually pretty
cool most of it is actually pretty fun
not all of it of course i mean you know
you can't it would be impossible to
dream up a job worth literally you loved
every single thing but for many of us we
are in the extremely fortunate position
where most of what we do is actually
quite interesting and quite meaningful
but
there's a big but
it's that we
often
are forced to do so much of it in such a
compressed amount of time that we
actually
have a hard time enjoying any of it
even if on its own it would be fun it
would be interesting it would be good
it's really hard to enjoy something when
you're in a speed round or you know when
you
you know one scoop of ice cream is great
uh eating 25 scoops of ice cream is
gonna make you throw up
and so i think the question is how can
we just buy ourselves a little bit more
margin because just even a little bit
more space
in our lives to be able to slow down to
appreciate things to
be in the moment is what is going to
give us the ability to have that balance
to have the inputs but be able to think
about it and do something about it
there's a folk band that i really like
called the nilds and they have a
song lyric that i think applies
in many ways to our present predicament
um
they uh they say that the difference
between neurosis and psychosis is only
two hours of sleep
and i think with our jobs and with our
professional lives it's actually pretty
similar that you know
most of us have probably
tried to optimize and life hack our way
to a lot of things right i i am making
an educated guess here that most people
in this uh in this auditorium are not
actually the people who are spending 17
hours a week watching television right
it's not like oh just watch television
you can get it all done like no i get it
that's not what you're doing you are
actually legitimately incredibly busy
but
the battle
in many ways is one at the edges
this is about
reclaiming even an hour
two hours if we can manage but even an
hour a week
if we can weed whack our way through it
if we can fend off
excess commitments and frankly no one
else is going to do it for you you have
to be the vigilant gatekeeper here but
if you can buy yourself back an hour a
week
it gives you
space
to be able to enjoy things a little bit
more and to just think a little bit more
clearly to begin to get that space
that's necessary for long-term thinking
indeed um i took a couple questions from
the audience here elizabeth um
is asking what are you personally bad at
what have you decided to to be bad at um
and how has this worked in your strategy
oh it's such a good question uh so one
thing that i am super deliberately bad
at is i have never really learned to
cook properly
and so i
live part time in new york
and i buy all my food i just buy it out
and uh in miami i uh i pay someone to
make meals for me uh i i have just
realized it's not it's not worth the the
time and the learning some people
actually really relax in the kitchen i
find it incredibly stressful so i've
given up on that we have to be willing
to make the choice and to understand all
right i may not be able to prioritize
this or to go all in on this at this
time nice yeah i chose to never match my
socks again i got all black socks
i don't know how much time that saves me
a lot less cognitive load on my socks
anyway um and marianasenko um
is asking i think maybe how to expand
this thinking more in institutionally
given that the majority of our
institutions and companies exist on the
short timelines decades at best how how
could we incentivize them in a more
institutional environment and i and even
to that point one of the things i've
learned in my research about long-lived
companies is that the fortune 500
companies have in the 1950 were lasting
61 years and now they're less than 18
years old
before so there's we're losing almost
one year per year of of corporate
longevity um in and of itself so it's an
interesting statistic for how that's
working
yes well i i am super eager for your
research standard because i feel like
you are going to answer this question in
a very definitive way
but i also i i think it's
it's hard honestly i mean a big part of
the reason
going back to one of the points in the
talk
a huge reason that amazon is able and
willing to make long-term choices is
well
the guy who started it was running it
and
he was very comfortable with that
from the beginning i mean you know props
props where it's due
um
jeff bezos was willing to beat the drum
from the minute amazon went public don't
expect profits don't expect profits we
are reinvesting and that was that was
the terms um they were
very deliberate about reattaching
that letter that original shareholder
letter to every subsequent shareholder
letter is a reminder for anyone who
might erroneously think that profits
would be coming i mean now of course
profits are rolling in but it took a
really long time because they were
willing to defer a deferred fur and
invest
and
i actually think that that structurally
it is
extremely hard because if you do not
have
the owner
who is
running it you have a lot of people who
in our current climate i mean i know
people at the long now foundation are in
it for the long term you have been here
from the beginning i know danielle has
been here for 16 years i mean the
longevity is amazing because of
because of the the commitment the
commitment to the vision and that sort
of shared understanding but in most
corporate jobs i mean we know this if
somebody stays you know 25 years 16
years at a corporate job we're like what
you know it's like oh my god they're
from the 50s uh it's incredibly rare and
as a result of that um people are making
choices that are
optimized for themselves rather than for
the entity and so if you have a super
mission-driven organization where
everyone is bought into that shared
vision which you know that that's a
powerful thing for a company to create
then we might be able to overcome the
natural bias of self-interest but
without that it's it's really hard to do
um adam is asking um
what is some long-term thinking or
strategic advice that you think is
dangerous or disagree with
that's great dangerous long-term
thinking well i i think that it
an example of of you know
dangerous long-term thinking
would be
this
in general we know human nature is
optimized for the short term right i
mean for any of us just rationally if
you can have a good thing now or if you
can have a good thing in 20 years well
sure let's take the good thing now
that's that's sort of how we are we have
to consciously override it
to
become
sufficient long-term thinkers and for
some things you need to because for
certain meaningful hard worthy goals
you're only going to get there the only
path to it is long-term thinking
in general that is a good thing it is
worth aspiring to where it becomes
dangerous is the following
and my friend marshall goldsmith he says
that something that we often
um
fail to to do you know we get so good
at saving for the rainy day we get so
good at deferring gratification
some of us actually err on the side of
never properly celebrating our
accomplishments i don't i don't think it
you could call it a real success
for somebody to
die
at the end of their lives
just having kept their head down and had
this
onerous
grueling existence because they keep
putting it off for another day another
day another day and they never actually
get to enjoy the fruits of what they've
done it doesn't mean you blow it it
doesn't mean that you are
celebrating excessively or you're not
putting aside money for charity or for
relatives or things like that but i
think it's
this kind of
abstemiousness can become a
self-perpetuating cycle
and it's important to celebrate the
victories and it's important to enjoy
our lives along the way
yeah now if you've ever sat with
somebody who's passed passing away they
never sit there and say i wish i worked
harder
they usually say i wish i took that
vacation so yeah um i said we're gonna
we're gonna wrap this up um but kevin
kelly is gonna get the the last question
um
what is your 10-year project that you
are working on
so my 10-year project i alluded to this
a little bit uh during during the talk
but in 2016
i decided that i was going to learn to
write musical theater and it actually
came out of a very specific circumstance
in 2015 the year before
i
went a little crazy with work i guess
you could say i was launching a book
and
i
and the honest truth was um i was
feeling a little
depressed and so
as a way of
burying that
i went on the road
and so i gave 74 talks that year
which was a lot uh it came out to about
one and a half talks every week
and so that meant i was
pretty much on a plane once or twice
every week and i was so incredibly
exhausted at the end of the year i was i
was sick i was just run down and i
thought you know why why am i doing this
why am i why did i decide it was a good
idea to run myself to the point of
exhaustion
and i was living in new york at the time
and i realized
why am i paying so much money to live in
new york when i'm not actually in new
york i'm just on planes it seemed really
ridiculous and so i came up with a new
year's resolution for myself and my new
year's resolution was that as a way of
leaning into the city as a way of kind
of reconnecting and appreciating where i
was
i was going to do one uniquely new york
activity per week something that you
could only do in new york so you know
maybe it's see a broadway show or go to
a museum or you know take a
you know dumpling tour of chinatown or
you know whatever it is
so one of the first things that i did
was a guy that i knew invited me to a
broadway show and so i said yes i will
go to that show with you it was like my
first week's activity
and i went to this show i went to see
fun home which won the 2016 yes won the
2016 tony award a really amazing show
and the truth was i lived in new york
about a year and a half by that point i
had only been to one broadway show i
really hadn't take advantage of that but
i saw this show and it just hit me and i
went home and i woke up the next morning
and i was seized with this feeling with
just this this sense
that i needed to learn to write musical
theater and i decided to pursue that and
i have done so since then and so i have
taken you know trainings and fellowships
and and moved it forward but what i've
come to learn
is that the average show that it's it's
a long process it takes about seven
years on average seven or eight years
for a show to go from inception to
actually making it to broadway there's a
lot of steps along the way so in 2016 i
decided that i would create a 10-year
goal for myself to have a
show on broadway for the 2026 season
so we're in 2022 so i'm working on it
thank you so much it's really great
thank you
[Music]